and Netflix fell in love with you we got
to find a show for this girl yes no I
don't know uh hands Jessica Jones yeah
Jessica Jones yeah which happened how
many years after
well I first I did the being apartment
23. yes that lasted a couple Seasons
yeah two seasons you love that show I do
I would do it again in a second Why
didn't it get picked up why it was a
listen it was on ABC it was right before
things the metrics sort of changed like
we got canceled for numbers that now are
considered like massive hits right
um it was kind of like scheduled badly
it just was kind of dragged around by a
[__] smeared dog didn't really but it
was also very edgy and we really pushed
the envelope the writing was way ahead
of its time and it was just one of those
like great little quirky shows that
probably probably served everybody
better by just being two seasons yeah
because it's like you know cult
following people love it I love it I
will watch it and laugh at every line
because the writing is so good do you
get upset how do you deal with
um cancellations or rejection I mean
obviously you started at a young age
with rejection everywhere it's just part
of it so when they said who called you
to tell you apartment uh yeah the [__]
from apartment 23. yeah that that was
the ACT that was the hardest rejection
that whatever it's all in the camera
because you were surprised I was
surprised but I also loved it so much
and I knew yes I cried but I would cry
before that there were days driving home
from set where I just had the best day
and I would go home I would drive home
crying knowing that it'll never be as
good as this again
I had the best day The Producers on that
show let me tell you Jeff Morton he is
he's a producer for Modern Family he's
done like a heat part of his whole
system is like let's make sure the cast
and the crew are rested and happy so
they could be funny who is that who is
that no one thinks that no one thinks
that and he is so special and I I would
I want to do another show with him so
badly because he cares about people I
want to work with Jeff Morton Jeff
Martin Jeff Martin Jeff Martin Jeff
I'll auditioned for you on tape he just
cared about that and we would shoot like
10 hour days
what comedies comedies and you know what
oh my God I felt so supported so
supported to like be able to push myself
even further so I all I was trying to do
all day was like get learn my funny
lines and how do I make them even
funnier how do I improvise this thing
how do I do this little weird character
thing because I was so supported that I
was able to be like free to [__] play
see this is an important thing you're
saying most
creators most
Studios whoever is involved in all this
process of making a show they don't
realize that and this goes not for just
acting World it goes to the entire
planet of people bosses out there
corporations if you treat the people yes
well if you support them you'll get
better and more you'll not only get
better performances and more passion and
more Dr it's just going to be a better
Show everybody's gonna be happier more
joy and they don't they always 90 of the
time they want to show how powerful they
are I'm not going to do that I'm not
going to give you the money you deserve
I'm not going to give you the hours
you're going to work overtime we're
going to force you we're changing this
who cares you're not even on they don't
care no and that is really refreshing to
hear that someone was that guy he was
that guy he was that guy and it was such
a magical experience but that was after
Breaking Bad so that was kind of like
did the Breaking Bad Thing and
at that before that I was like working
actress hustling just you know whatever
and then that was when I started to like
get offered things